ja man hat ihn getötet alter wo mein
gott ich habe somit die weise nicht den
heftigsten typen den ich in diesem spiel
kennen gelernt hab gerade getötet egal
was euch jetzt als bekommen schildert
living battlefield ist heftig schreiben
kommentare hallo ich in freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu minecraft
hier auf dem heck set server in
minecraft exit auf dem server so ich
werde jetzt zurück laufen zu diesem
komischen typen und werden jetzt kaputt
machen aber erst muss ich hier noch was
essen damit ich dem typen überhaupt
irgendwie bedrohlich werden kann weil
der hatte ja schon ein bisschen skill
muss man schon sagen wo ist er denn hin
gelaufen wo bist du
wo ist der typ da unten
komm mir nicht zu nahe
ein kleiner freund muss er hin muss er
da oben auch dann trifft einfach nicht
wert auf einmal wieder 118 leben
generierte die scheiße auch oder wie als
ob ich brauche jetzt ein heftiger kampf
als beute einfach ein
da kann ich ja gar nicht der kommt ja
immer wieder raus scheiße mann man
leichter in allen mitgliedern packe ihn
besiegen
wie soll ich das machen
ultra range ring skeleton die anzeigen
an der krems anderson ab quick sind
wer welchen treffe krieg selber schaden
welche treffe krieg selber schaden alter
der es heftig
kann ich dir nicht irgendwie wasser hier
einbuddeln dann treffe ich dir nicht
mehr im nahkampf
die mibrag das ganze ein bisschen hält
er verliert aber immer viel mehr leben
als ich den irgendwie abzieher oder so
traust du dich nicht aus mehr oder wenig
vor allem er trifft mich einfach immer
er trifft einfach wirklich immer durch
jetzt mal wieder ein bisschen rum
wir sehen ja mal oben jetzt eine leben
60 60 es bleibt bei 60 ich habe ihnen
gehört ich habe ihnen gehört ich wette
ist die pinguine sind wieder daran
schuld
jetzt laufe ich weg 60 bleibt bei 60
vorher hatte er aber wieder 120 weißig
generierte das denn irgendwie oder oder
wie immer noch 60
und was bedeutet überhaupt dieses rote
links heißt dass das einfach nur ein
moped oder oder wie jetzt habe ich
wieder hier paar minütchen nur mit
diesem café verschwindet jetzt kommt ja
noch da unten schild kann ich einfach
mal war einsetzen
hallo rudi hier bin ich
der ultimative zeitalters wirst du
sterben ja mein er wird sterben er wird
einfach sterben
ich töte den weiter und es passiert
nichts
er ist tot
ja man habe ihn getötet alter wo mein
gott ich habe somit die weise nicht den
heftigsten typen den ich in diesem spiel
kennen gelernt habe gerade getötet egal
was hab ich jetzt alles bekommen janet
living battlefield ist deftig schreiben
das mit kommentare es ist gut was hier
bekommen an breaking 1 spitzhacke und
noch eines ist das ein schock op dee
moment coupé die und was ist das auch
ein schock
ok und einfach mal zur feier des tages
steht mir leid bruder ach ja gut also
was du jetzt so aufgefallen ist einfach
eine ecke drängen diese komische leute
da aber egal man richtig viel erfahrung
bekommen
das war erstmal war war schon mal so ein
relativ guter kampf jetzt dieser jump
street mich ein bisschen auf wenn ich
kann ja gar nicht mehr so richtig
schnell laufen
ja ich mache mir dann denke ich einfach
noch ein scale rüstung ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob das irgendwie dann großartig
besser ist eine phoenix fehler meinte
tier auch soll ich mir machen weil man
damit in wien noch mal extra leben
bekommt wenig trainer gas tränengas
träne
das musste auch ein netter gen oder
playsport ja ich muss dafür eine wo h
ich bin vor mit feilen ich bin gut ich
wollte ich gar nicht dass jetzt schon
wieder hier fünf minuten mit diesem
ganzen tag hier verschwinden sondern ich
wollte einfach nur umziehen
aber ist ja egal wir haben jetzt auf
jeden fall eine coole spitzhacke
bekommen die zwar nicht wirklich besser
ist aber was dieses living battlefield
ist weil wir jetzt auch nicht so genau
ich kann es ja gleich noch mal testen
wenn er irgendwie neuer hotspot oder so
aber der war auf jeden fall schon mal
heftig vor allem ich wusste von so mops
die einfach mega stark sind oder die
einfach einen direkt von hinten oder so
aber der ist einfach am leben geblieben
teppich verlangsamt er hat mir effekte
auf mich drauf gegeben das einfach im
leben geblieben
ich weiß nicht warum das das von
komischer typ war aber da stand auch
etwas komisch ist über den da drüber und
so also motoren damit leben dass hier
für mich aber nicht hier neben meinem
grundstück haben so das erste was jetzt
nämlich machen werde ist die kiste
einfach mal mitnehmen
ziehen wir sich kraft im jetzt kisten
packt jeder note rocky und habe ich
nicht noch irgendwie kisten oder nötig
in sachen
hab ich irgendwie noch kisten weinkisten
übrigens danke für den tipp wenn ich
hier drauf drücken und dann liefert x
höhe würde mich verarschen irgendwie
meinte dass ich irgendwie so ein
fragezeichen sehe
achso so frage zeichnet dann habe ich
das hier drehen
das ist gut danke meine freunde das eben
ihr das beigebracht hat in den
kommentaren
die können wir nun übrigens auch ganz
viele andere tipps in den kommentaren
reinschreiben weil ich werde auf jeden
fall immer drauf eingehen damit ich auch
ein bisschen vorankommen hexel soll
diese sachen damit wollte ich auch in
meinem haus bauen
ich gucke mal auf die uhr nebenbei damit
ich hier auf jedenfalls nicht bis der
bescheid so ich wollte mir kisten
kräften dafür brauche ich das doofe holz
was ich in meinem ganzen leben nie
verwenden werde so nur 22 die stelle ich
mir manchmal da hinten hin
da komme ich mir braucht eigentlich eh
mehr
die kisten hier muss ich ja eigentlich
eh stehen lassen wegen dieses dings wege
hiermit kann ich noch mit meinem papa
damit auch trainer machen
wegen diesem lager da was ich bauen
wollte so viel das sollte erstmal
grundsätzlich passen so etwa die
wichtigsten sachen drüber reden kann
wenn ich dann vom thema so hier wohne
ich dann schön das ist aber schön so ich
weiß noch nicht ganz genau ich das
machen werde kann ich nicht mit mabel
irgendwie ich nutze jetzt über
aneinander nein du kommt natürlich mit
kenne ich nutze mal hier einfach dann
den crafting table von unserem
waffenmeister werden crafting table
alter das ein toller waffen
ich lebe jetzt einfach mein mixa das
eine
ihr habt schon gehört dass auch ihr habt
schon gehört meine nase sie sitzen
blieben
das liegt aber seit ich das wirklich
daraus machen oder einfach aus puren
marble oder ich glaube sogar dass man
sieht dass noch besser aus dies setzt
ein bisschen zu meiner nase das legen
ich kann auch nichts für ich habe
eigentlich ganz gutes immunsystem
nee das geht nicht auf buben habe das
geht nur aus den hier
es ist halt die frage möchte ich den
boden wirklich daraus machen sieht das
denn schön raus überhaupt erstmal
positiver schön aus den kellerboden
machen
ich werde halt wirklich weil entweder
aus birthplace burt white plains also
ich hab wirklich gute ideen aber soll
ich da raus und ich glaube ich mache aus
dem virgin classics dem boden
das heißt ich brauche das und davon
viele
so das brauche ich alles hinschmeißt mal
kurz weg und jetzt zeige ich erst mal
ganz kurz um groben groben umrisse
gruppen grob baugruppen leer keine
ahnung
ach guck mal hier käfer dass er schon
aus diesen komischen babbel briggs
deswegen möchte das dann einfach nicht
da brat darauf da wird hier nicht drin
da wohnt eigentlich gar keiner der hier
wohnt gar keine
das heißt das kann ja theoretisch
eigentlich so ein bisschen da ich möchte
das jetzt halt ein bisschen achte ich
möchte eigentlich schon relativ in die
mitte oder ich mach das fällt vielleicht
auch einfach weg muss ich noch mal könig
kay dort fragen wo es natürlich können
nicht einfach da hier die mitte so geht
man hier so hoch das heißt hier das ziel
kommt weg das hier kommt weg und das
hier kommt weg und dann kommt hier hier
hier ein etwas hin
dann kommt hier eine tür rein
hier kommen dann die vollen hin die hier
obwohl ich den boden eventuell sogar aus
anderen sache machen wollte die zeit sie
rennt 3 4 1 2 3 4
ach man ich dachte das funktioniert
jetzt so
so das war's das ist mein haus herr breu
nicht zum leben
das wunderschön so ich wollte erst mal
ganz kurz die erde ab die ich brauche um
packt die da mal eben da vorne rein
ach das ist mehr als viele so dass das
so nicht so komisch zusetzt und dann
kommt hier der boden aus auch diesem
hellen birkenholz daran habe ich mich
verliebt in diesem zweck sechser pack
wisst ihr habt ihr glaube ich schon in
der ersten folge nahezu mitbekommen und
dann wird daher die tür reinkommen und
dann habe ich mir gedacht dass ich auch
aus redwood so half length steps machen
werde
hiervon habe ich ja gar nicht mehr
soviel verdammt verdammt
die ganze erde nehme ich jetzt einfach
mal dass der gast kommt jetzt aber mit
die kisten kann ich ja mal schon mal
aufstellen die sollen zwar eigentlich
woanders hin kommen aber ich stelle
jetzt einfach erst mal hier hin und hier
hin da packt jetzt erstmal hier so die
ganzen bausachen rhein ihr wisst
bescheid wie es läuft so dass hier
sortiere ich auch mal eben sondern werde
ich nämlich endlich auch mal eine ganze
kisten hier sortieren so viele doofe
spitzhacken das ist unglaublich darauf
zwei fackeln die pfeile wiese stecken
sich die pfeile nicht mein gott so
die fehler bei auf jeden fall die
software kaputt hier bildet living metal
macht protection 1 einfach nur seinen
sohn schwert und schild legt sich das
wenn ich das jetzt komplett leer mache
dass das geht eigentlich relativ schnell
ist das leer ist so so jetzt ist der
schutz weg sieht sich das wieder
aufwachte und derzeit kann ich jetzt
nicht blocken
also dass es ganz gut wenn ich mich mal
heil muss weil wenn ich doch der beste
eigentlich auch brauchten fast all die
jahre nur so können auch die toto
verrückt
das erst mal hier rein jeder dieser
anderen komischen sachen die ich ähnlich
brauchen werde
ich dachte das sieht schön aus und dann
bräuchte ich auch gar nicht mehr
gebraten blöde sache so ich muss mir von
euch das überhaupt da
dafür brauche ich mir und zwar so viel
innerer kampf ganz viel bei nelly
furtado du bleibst da drin
oder war das ich glaube das kann doch
korrekt gewesen sind craig ist auf jeden
fall doof wie könner crack immer so viel
schaden zufügen dass der fast bei null
ist dann können wir ihm auseinander
halten weil tracks natürlich cool alle
feiern krekar letzte video die
kommentare queck geschrieben dieses
video ist jetzt mehr so produktiv ich
mache ich hab das chocobos richtig
bekommen ich bin umgezogen obwohl einige
meinten thema da bleiben aber da ja
jungs manchmal müssen einfach
veränderungen im leben kommen jungs und
das ist gut so einfach durch die tür
kraft so
so habe ich ein bisschen viel gemacht
aber egal so das wird mein häuschen
ich werde das hier das ist immer noch
ein bisschen breit finde ich also das
ist noch nicht so breit wie ich mir das
auf jeden fall vorstellen
weil wenn ich die kiste noch da hinten
stehen habe mal ganz theoretisch am ende
des hauses wo ich kann das haus auch ein
bisschen lang gezogener machen
beschäftigt kisten einfach an rand
wertet das hab ich dann habe ich auch
eine gute idee
also ich mach das gerade hier alles
spontan ich habe mir hier keine pläne
ich ein bisschen ausgelaugt wie es
eventuell machen werde
aber ich habe jetzt noch keine heftigen
pläne irgendwie dazu überlegt die jetzt
so alles zerbersten sind sondern das
meiste ist hier wirklich gerade einfach
nur spontan das canvas wieder alles raus
gekloppt ist auch schöner hätte also die
chocobos da bin ich mitten im stadtkern
da muss nur noch daran irgendwas hin
damit sie sich ganz so leer als schön
eine leinwand ex hier die komischen
körperlichen wieder hin
gleich kommt die betroffen sind und ich
bin tot das wäre auf jeden fall auch
cool oder wäre dass schwul
jetzt hat es geklappt ach so ich muss
jetzt also seitlich dran setzen dann
klappt's okay
bla bla bla bla bla bla verkauf klappt
so dann ist das meine wohnfläche
ich hab noch gar nicht abgeschätzt ob
das jetzt bei pasta die kiste da gehe
ich jetzt einfach nicht dran
ich brauch noch mehrere kisten
ich habe er genug von diesem holz
mittlerweile deswegen kann ich das jetzt
einfach mal so 10 reichen glaube ich
nicht machen
kombiniert ist nicht wirklich auf die
schulter der abgestürzt oder tatsache
scheiße starb es war aber eher nicht
abgehört
wieso kann ich mit einem block machen
der so cool hoch leuchtet den stelle ich
mir irgendwie obendrauf warte ich gucke
noch ganz kurz ob das jetzt eben passt
oder nach macht denn neben den cut und
zwar wenn man reinkommt
sachlichkeit auch eigentlich hier testen
so so so so so so so etwas nicht klappt
es auf jeden fall nicht das heißt ich
muss auf einen weiter nach hinten gehen
auf der anderen seite weil dann kommt
doch ich muss noch auf jeden fall noch
eine breite gehen auf beiden seiten
chancen gut dass werde ich dann einfach
beim nächsten mal mache meine lieben
freunde weil ich jetzt gleich auch schon
wieder hier fertig bereit zum
durchstarten bin und dann wenn ich das
mal machen wenn ihr noch irgendwelche
tipps hat bezüglich bau des hauses et
cetera pp dann könnten wir das ganz
einfach in die kommentare schreiben
wer auf jeden fall mehr sinnvoll und
wartet dann mache ich mir schon mal so
eine kleine gedankenstütze und bauen das
ganze schon mal einen nach hinten damit
ich weiß wo ich das nächste mal
auffallen soll muss weitermachen muss
nicht aufhören soll wenn ich das nächste
mal dann hier aufnehmen und zwar geht
das ganze dann hier weiter hier hier und
hier geht also ein bisschen ins haus
rein aber das geht mir zu uns verleiht
das relativ egal
und da will ich sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich definitiv
bei einer bewertung freuen
aber nur wenn es euch gefallen wenn es
euch nicht gefallen hat müsst ihr das
nicht machen und das hier wird an mein
haus und ich denke das wird eigentlich
ganz schön und wir können das hier mal
angucken wie ihr euch denkt dass sie
ganz schön mittig und und wird es noch
ein bisschen höher so zedelius haus
obwohl ich hier immer noch ein bisschen
zentral und ja natürlich sagen
tschüss